this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hey minimizers welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists so you've started
decluttering your physical clutter
congratulations it's time to move on now
what about all that digital clutter on
your computer your phone your tablet and
other devices
is it taking up space
on your hard drive
is it also taking up space in the back
of your mind
that's we're talking about today we're
talking about computer clutter digital
clutter
all of that electronic clutter that is
burdening you and your life we're
broadcasting in front of our first ever
studio audience today
we're gonna talk about them a little bit
later in the episode during our right
here right now segment we have danny and
mallory and emma here and of course
podcast sean and jordan no more are all
here i think we have to determine
nicknames for each person today or maybe
they can let us know in the comments on
youtube we'll save that for right here
right now but first ryan i have this
question from lonnie where she said what
are the benefits of not having digital
clutter taking up space in the back of
your mind that question came from our
facebook page
and
i want to posit that question back to
you lonnie because that's the question
i'm glad you're asking that question
because that is the question that makes
sense to start with quite often we start
with well how do i remove the clutter in
my life how do i remove the digital
clutter what digital clutter is
appropriate for me but maybe the best
question is how might my life be better
with less or in lonnie's case what are
the benefits
of having
less digital clutter in my life
and the reason you want to ask yourself
that is because if i answer that
question for you or if ryan answers that
question for you
well then you're just going to know the
benefits for me are the benefits for
ryan and we might share some of the same
benefits but ultimately
what are the benefits for you that's
what we want to talk about today in this
episode ryan i wanted to start by
talking about i just got this new
computer here right oh wow yeah
minimalist
you you helped me well my last computer
the it just started typing wise which is
a strange metaphor it's like why why
why
just randomly i'd be in the middle of a
document all the time i look up and
there's like 400 y's
and um i mean ryan and i do try to get
to the why of things sure but that was a
bit ridiculous and i put up with it for
about a year random things were
happening it was turning off on its own
sometimes the space bar would get stuck
mouse wouldn't work yeah it was many
years old trackpad i guess yes yeah
and
you know what it was time for a new
computer and so good run it did yeah you
ordered a new one for me yes and i
actually ordered a particular one gave
you the specs
and
then you're like hey man they don't have
the hard drive size you're looking for
the one they have in stock right now is
the smallest hard drive that they have
yeah it was like half of what you're
asking for maybe even a fourth yeah
maybe and and so i'm like okay cool
that's fine i'm one of the minimalists i
don't need any space
and so i i well first off i got to say i
went into
i went into
the
mall where you had ordered it and i got
that overwhelmed so it was at the
beverly center oh man it's even like
particularly overwhelming when you go in
yeah it's like a fancy mall right
and so i go into the computer store and
and go to pick up the item i also was
getting a computer for sean at the same
time because he had been having problems
very similar to mine yeah the planned
obsolescence they're out to get us ryan
i don't think that's what it is i think
our devices they wear out over time and
of course
um we often replace them although we
have something called the don't upgrade
rule which maybe we can talk about
sometime during this episode well you
know what's interesting when you guys
got new computers i was like oh well
this is an excuse for me to get a new
computer that's right we might as well
get new computers all around the ditaro
effect yes i talked to myself out of it
so the ditaro effect it usually applies
like if you buy something new for your
house or a new electronic gadget now i
need to upgrade everything else
oh i just bought this fancy new couch
well now my coffee table looks stupid
yeah it just like never ends yeah and it
like kicks off this consumerist cycle
and i think it's even more pervasive
with our electronics because these
things we think need to be replaced more
frequently yeah i i'm not gonna lie like
i
when i say i look for excuses i don't
really look for excuses but you know my
impulse is to upgrade whenever something
new comes out yes and like i do look for
justifications of like oh you know what
i can go ahead and get an upgraded
whatever and uh yeah i'm glad i didn't
because like the one i have is still
works great it needs a new battery but
that's not a big deal
um but yeah man it would have been it
would have been a waste of money well
let's talk about that then so let's
let's take a bit of a detour so in our
new book it's called love people use
things if you're watching on youtube
it'll hold up so you can take a look at
the cover here but
i love people use things we have these
16 rules for living with less you can
also download those rules for free over
at
theminimalists.com rulebook you get a
free ebook over there as well one of
those rules is the don't upgrade rule
and this applies specifically it can
apply to anything but specifically to
our gadgets and our computers our
smartphones etc and it's really about
that impulse that we get every time
something new comes out we see on a
billboard or tv ad or whatever now i
feel as though i'm not complete with out
that thing and so the don't upgrade rule
says hey there are three alternatives to
upgrading number one and this one is
really challenging in our society it's
go without
i know right wait a minute my phone
broke
can i go without it for a day a week a
month maybe not but maybe there's
something else my tv broke yeah i can
probably go without that for a while and
it's not to deprive yourself but to see
okay does this actually add value to my
life the second thing is if you can't go
without it you can rip you can repair
the thing so as you talked about your
computer sometimes it's like well i just
need a new battery yeah if my the brakes
went out on my car i'd be like well i
guess i need a new car
what makes me think of in the corporate
days i literally would go buy a new car
every two years because at that two year
mark i'd have to do tires i'd have to do
you know all this maintenance and i
would justify and be like well it's
gonna cost me two thousand dollars to do
all this maintenance or i could just get
a new car
yeah anyway we can justify anything
that's what the the don't upgrade rule
does for us it helps us realize the
absurdity of some of these
justifications that we have in our own
lives and the third thing is if you
can't go without and if it can't be
repaired maybe you ran over your phone
in the driveway or whatever you need to
replace it okay the third option is
maybe you can buy something used
that's the equivalent or maybe you can
even in some cases quote downgrade
because here's another way to think
about upgrades every upgrade is also in
some way a downgrade
now here's what i mean by that by buying
this new computer i upgraded my computer
i also downgraded my bank account mm-hmm
in doing that well also your bank
account because it was sorry about that
ryan that's right
but so every upgrade that we have in our
lives is a downgrade in some other area
of our life what's the quote from thomas
soul podcast sean
there are no solutions only trade-offs
and sometimes the trade-off makes sense
to give up some money for the thing that
is going to serve a purpose in my life
back to buying this computer so i get it
home after the chaotic terrifying trip
to the beverly center and it's
overwhelming of course every time i go
to the beverly center actually that's
the first time since we've lived in los
angeles i've been there i've been there
one other time i've gone to the grove
once or twice to go see a movie but
anytime i go to a shopping mall well you
learn that a lot of people know who the
minimalists are
what are the minimalists doing in a
shopping mall did you get recognized
yeah yeah like six times i'm waiting in
line because they had this huge line
outside the store wow because of
capacity issues and so i'm waiting in
line
and people walking by oh hey minimalist
what are you buying at the mall
like i swear i need it
i feel compelled to get it up for a
friend
oh i get that all the time i know i look
a lot like him
but
anyway anyway so i get home with this
computer and i you know you do like the
transfer you can you can move all of
your data and photos and files and all
this stuff and i start the the transfer
and you know it takes several hours and
in the middle of it just says hey you
don't have enough space on this new
computer this can't be these files from
your old computer cannot be transferred
to your new computer wow and so in that
moment i i got overwhelmed like oh no
what am i going to do
and then i realized like oh i know what
i'm going to do delete all the porn
[Laughter]
save that a hard drive oh okay okay yeah
no i'm going to start anew
and so i started with this computer with
literally
none of my old files oh well it's
freeing in a way it sounds like it was
so i mean it's still freeing right now
you realize how little you miss now i'll
talk about some of the particulars in
this episode also on the maximum episode
this week we're going to talk about the
digital clutter challenge we're gonna
give you a bunch of tools for
simplifying your digital life but on
this minimal episode i thought we'd talk
about the freedom of letting go of some
of the digital clutter and we're gonna
answer some of your questions let's
start with emily from instagram
what do you define as digital clutter i
think first we have to define what
clutter is clutter is anything that gets
in the way right so clutter for me
may not be clutter for you and vice
versa right right and so if something is
clutter for you right now
or clutter for me right now and it's not
clutter for you it could be clutter for
you in the future if it begins to get in
the way now get in the way of what now
it could be it gets in the way of our
stuff
if the average american household has
hundreds of thousands of items in it
the problem with that is many of those
things get in the way of the useful
things how many times when we're out on
the road or a tour stop or we're talking
to people or
and they say you know what i had some
things that were really useful to me
that i forgot i even had because they
were hiding
behind the materialistic clutter in my
basement or my closet or whatever else
or i had i think this is most pronounced
in our clothes you know when people say
i didn't even remember i had that shirt
that i really enjoy because it was
covered up by all these other shirts
that i hate wearing but i have never let
go of well can't that be true with our
digital clutter as well it is digital
clutter only if it gets in the way right
and so i thought that was an important
question to start with because defining
what gets in the way identifying how do
we even know it gets in the way well
does it stress you out does it feel like
a burden is it preventing you from using
certain things in your home or is it
just weighing on the back of your mind
that's a type of burden as well that's
all clutter and i don't want to live
with clutter now of course decluttering
is not something that you do
with respect to the letting go part the
letting goes when you stop holding on to
these things and i think that's really
our big problem with
well with all this digital clutter on
the computers on our phones wherever
else
is we hold on to everything until it
gets to that point where it's untenable
yeah and so when ryan you did your
packing party and you let go of a whole
bunch of stuff but that's not where the
decluttering stopped it wasn't like okay
i decluttered once 10 12 years ago
whenever that was 2009 maybe 2010 yeah
2010. yeah and so 11 years ago
when you did that actually wow it'll be
11 years ago next month that's crazy
yeah and and so but that was the start
of the process but it's still about
questioning
the digital clutter the physical clutter
that you bring in that you hold on to
and that you let go of it's a process of
questioning the clutter because the
things that are useful today
might be clutter tomorrow you can tweet
that podcast sean boom we have a
question here from twitter maria has
something for us where do we start in
addressing digital clutter to ensure we
stay focused and motivated and not get
overwhelmed with it all create folders
first and then view every single file to
put it in the right folder is there a
faster method
feels like we'll be forced to touch each
and every file in the process that is
overwhelming right yeah if you felt like
you had to
go to the internet and declutter the
internet i know this is an extreme
example you you couldn't do it even even
a website like wikipedia who
who has people and volunteers who
go through pour through pages to
de-clutter those
pages and apparently clutter our
wikipedia page
do they with criticism
no um everyone needs a little criticism
i guess yeah yeah i suppose so or at
least some feedback right
anyway um you couldn't declutter the
entire internet and so what's freeing
about that is you have access to it
without having ownership of it
and so in a way
the internet enables us in fact that's
why i didn't need all of the extra
storage space on my computer
is i had all of my other stuff backed up
onto dropbox
and we're actually we're going to talk
about a few other photo storage services
on the maximum episode that i think will
be helpful for folks but i just had all
my stuff on dropbox my email is in the
quote cloud you know whether it's gmail
or whatever email service that you use
it's out there and yes of course there's
a certain level of trust that you have
in these services but what's more
important than that trust
it's the not needing any of it
and that's what i really learned because
yes let's say i lost all my photos from
well my mom
ella's childhood photos all of these
things these things are important to me
but i also don't need them
and the moment i don't need them anymore
i actually enjoy them
so much more so let's get back to
maria's question here
i think of in the medical field we call
it palliative care right where you sort
of give someone a
you ease the symptoms
but you don't cure
the cancer right and i mean that's an
extreme example but i think sometimes
what we're trying to do is ease this the
symptoms
of our digital clutter without getting
to the root of that digital clutter yeah
in a way yeah
well again i mean the question is you
know basically how do i do this and not
feel overwhelmed how do i you know
declutter digitally and not feel
overwhelmed
here's the thing is like you have spent
years and years and years of like
building all this up
it is overwhelming yes now the easy
solution is and i'll never forget that
uh gentleman at one of our tour stops
he's like man i've got like he like even
came up to the stage and showed us he's
like i got these all these saved links
i'm gonna like read these one day yeah
he's in dallas yeah that's what i keep
telling myself and and sometimes i do
read them on a board you know or i have
some time i'll go to those links but
he's like i add more links
than what i actually read it's kind of
like someone who buys more books than
what they actually read
and i just looked at i'm like you really
want my advice he's like he's like yeah
i was like all right i'm just gonna put
myself in your shoes i would delete them
all
i would delete it right now in front of
everyone yeah and he was like he was so
like i don't know just stopped in his
tracks eyes wide and he was like
all right man i'll do it and yeah he
like deleted every and like the relief
that he had it was like his shoulders
were even like a little looser after he
did it so you know i just just you know
kind of an extreme example
maria of you could just get rid of it
all and start new but here's the thing
is if you do have important
digital items whether it's photos or tax
records which we'll talk a little bit
about too here in a little bit um
it is a lot to filter through
but that's that's it though man like
minimalism and simplicity it's not easy
it is a lot of work yes it's a lot of
calling it's a lot of uh asking yourself
questions introspection it's it's it is
a lot of work so
it's okay to feel overwhelmed but you
know i
you know if you if you do have to go
through some stuff you said overwhelm
maybe is some
leverage because you don't ever want to
feel like this again such a good point
uh j krishnamurti says
use your suffering to ease your
suffering
and
and so when i think about
the overwhelm that's a type of suffering
right
it's a it's a low-grade suffering in a
way
and why do we feel overwhelmed i'm going
to start not with the how to because she
asked for some methods and we can get to
some methods that i think will be
helpful but i'm going to start with the
why to
why am i so overwhelmed by this stuff
well it's because i collected this
unintentionally over the course of
years years maybe even decades yeah it's
now the good news is it's not going to
take you years and decades right to to
get it in a way that doesn't overwhelm
you but it is going to take more than a
day it's going to be between one day and
a decade
it's it's the good news is it's not
going to take you more than a month and
yet it's not going to happen today most
likely either unless you drop it all and
start a new like i did with this
computer the cool thing about that is i
actually didn't have to do anything i
simply got the computer
and i didn't have to do anything
the relief had nothing to do with the
doing
it had to do with the not doing yeah
because at first what did i want to do
what is the right system what's the
right method how do i transfer this and
then how do i go in and declutter these
things as well
well the quickest way for me to
declutter my computer
was to start afresh without whether
that's re formatting the whole thing
starting over that way
and then guess what i have done since
then i've slowly reintroduced things
that i had backed up to the cloud that i
absolutely needed but only when i needed
them it was like a packing party for my
computer in a way oh wow because that's
awesome the truth is all the stuff's out
there and i know that i'm never going to
use most of it
just like the internet i know i'm never
going to use most of them i have it
backed up in the cloud
and yes could something happen to it so
at some point in time of course just
like my favorite website could go down
and now i'll no longer have access to
that either that's not a good reason why
i better print out the whole website
and then keep it in a binder yeah oh my
gosh could you imagine yes i can i have
ocd ryan
well dude i'll tell you what when i go
to youtube it is like i avoid youtube as
much as i can if i go to youtube like i
i needed to uh instill install this um
like hitch on my vehicle
so i
researched how to install and there's
like
all this clutter of installing it and
then i'm like which one i mean it's
overwhelming yes and so then i just went
to my friend and let him do it let him
do it but uh
but yeah man it's yeah it's crazy i mean
let alone youtube not to mention all the
other websites out there yeah well marie
i'm going to talk about some of the
actual methods that ryan and i go
through personally what i've gone
through on my new computer what i go
through on my phone as well we'll talk
about those on the maximal episode this
week patreon.com the minimalist all
right we got a question here from daniel
in new york city new york
one area of life and a hobby that i've
always enjoyed um
is video games and
unfortunately there is
a huge financial cost
i that i can see
to the hobby itself as a video game for
video gaming and everything and for
geeks i guess in general with that um
and as i'm seeking to kind of minimalize
minimalize and
downsize and simplify life um what what
is a a good way of approaching that
hobby to to make it
a more
minimal impact on on the rest of my life
i i want to still enjoy it but i also
don't want it to encroach on other areas
of my life such as importantly
my family
so ryan i know that you play video games
from time to time and this is exactly
what i mean by clutter this is something
that has added value to daniel's life at
some point and right now he feels as
though that area of his life is
cluttered it's affecting his family it's
affecting him yeah he's overwhelmed
right yeah and so the thing that he
talked about was the financial cost of
it yeah man i wouldn't be worried about
that cost just yet that's fourth or
fifth on your list
there are these other costs it's costing
you time and attention and energy and
maybe even skills that's not to say
video games are wrong or bad they're not
you can certainly enjoy them but at some
point that joy when it turns into
discontent that's when some decluttering
needs to take place ryan i know you've
set up some boundaries for yourself
around this sure man so
uh he he mentioned costs and i will talk
about that because it's
you pay money for your games
so it's like that's a the low-hanging
fruit of like well i can't throw away
that game because i paid money for it oh
cost yeah a lot of these games like 50
60
even worse there are games in the past
that i've purchased that are now free
that
there's i would never get the money back
regardless because now you can get it
you can get the game for free so yes uh
you said sunk cost and that's exactly
what i would encourage daniel to look at
these games that you spent 60 bucks on
that's fine just you don't need to feel
guilty about
spending the money
um
because that guilt is basically keeping
him from letting go
so and then the way to let go for me
like i have uh you know i got like my
gaming console we're not sponsored by
any gaming console so i won't mention
what it is but it has like a limit
of space on there okay now i can go buy
bigger hard drives and create more space
and have all the video games i want but
i don't i just have that one
storage that's in my video game and uh
yeah i mean i had i had a game that i
was playing that i never finished
and then my cousin calls me up he's like
hey man we should start playing you know
whatever and i'm like okay so i go to i
go to download this new game and it's
like you don't have room so now i'm
faced with a choice of like okay which
game am i gonna get rid of and it was
eating at me i'm like well you haven't
even finished this one game uh-huh and
i'm like what am i doing like i just i
got rid of it it was a
it was uh uh uh
san andreas oh man uh grand theft auto
anyway yeah so i deleted it and the
beautiful thing is is like when you when
you buy the video games
especially because now you can buy them
in the cloud you don't have to buy the
discs anymore right
so
i purchased that if i ever want to go
back to it i can cert i have access to
it oh wow okay
yeah so so with respect to gaming and i
think the real cost that he's dealing
with and a lot of people who become
addicted to playing video games is it's
their time
there's only 24 hours in a day and we
see the most exaggerated examples of
this right where we have someone who is
putting a diaper on and playing for 18
hours a day right right
and that's really
what i would suggest daniel look at is
like what is it costing you uh going
back to that term of clutter
what are the video games getting in the
way of
if you know if it's if it's uh
contention between you and your spout
like if mariah was like
you know uh you spend too much time on
video games and i would either get rid
of the video games or be like okay well
you know what can i you know what can i
do for you
to help you feel like i love you and and
i pay attention to you whatever it is i
mean luckily like she's she's like the
coolest
woman i've ever had who was totally like
play player video games
right in the past it has been a point of
contention right and it's a point of
contention because of two things one is
expectation someone else's expectations
with ella last night and i told her that
her
uh
her expectations
uh or her happiness was moderated by her
expectations she looked at me she goes i
don't even want to know what that means
yeah and and and yet so we have
expectations of other people those
things often make us miserable but also
the point of contention is this might
not be the best use of my time and i
think sometimes we know that we're doing
the easy thing
and we're first forsaking the important
things so in love people use things our
new book for example we have these six
questions to ask before buying something
but one of those questions is is this
the best use of my money or another way
to put that is is this the best use of
this resource right what is one of your
other resources well we have five main
resources that we use on a daily basis
it's time attention energy skills and
money and so it actually spells an
acronym teams we don't put money first
because then we meets
what is this arby's
and and so how are you using the time is
this yes maybe you're getting value from
the video games if you're feeling
discontent by it though maybe it's
because
well i don't feel like this is the best
use of my time right now and other times
if you have an hour to spare it could be
the best use of that time to quote
decompress or to
share an experience with someone else
and quite often uh there's a connection
especially now with video games because
you're connecting with people who you
know or in some cases people you've
never even met but it's that sense of
connection and it's creating a a sort of
community or a type of community
sometimes a faux community
and it
it all of a sudden you know they say
that connection is the antidote to
addiction
right well
maybe if we feel addicted to the video
game it's because we're not connected to
enough people in in our own lives yeah i
love the that you brought up the rules
because as i'm sitting here and going
through the 16 rules we have
a lot of those can be applied to video
games the seasonality rule yeah the uh
the 2020 rule especially if like you
already
have the game in the cloud you can
in less than 20 minutes you can start
downloading it again for free for less
than 20 yeah so um yeah daniel take a
look at those 16 rules because that's
really what it is about setting up
boundaries and those are going to be
highly perspectival and if it's
contention with your wife talk to your
wife about setting up those boundaries
yeah you can set up some boundaries
together not boundaries that are
restrictive in fact a few weeks we're
going to talk about some of the
boundaries since we have some new folks
we're working with now we've set up some
boundaries here in the workplace because
some boundaries increase our tranquility
increase our freedom we're gonna talk
about 25 different boundaries that ryan
and i have set up in our own lives
individually or together with with the
business as well we're gonna talk about
that in a few weeks on one of the
maximal episodes really dive deep but
daniel i would love to see you in new
york city yeah that event is getting
ready to sell out pretty soon we're
coming to 20 different cities across the
united states and canada we're going to
start out in texas we'll be in san
antonio and
houston and dallas and then we're going
to be in nashville and orlando and
atlanta and phoenix and denver and salt
lake city i'm doing this off top of my
head here boston and in new york city
and then dc and toronto and chicago and
minneapolis columbus we'll be back in
ohio finally
i say chicago already we'll be in
vancouver and seattle and los angeles
and san francisco and several other
places the minimalists.com tour podcast
sean if you could reach out to daniel
and give him a couple tickets to that
new york city event before it sells out
anyone else wants to get their tickets
the minimalists.com
tour ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it's time for the lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to
937-202-4654 yes indeed send us a text
message let us know what kind of digital
clutter you're letting go of this week
ryan and i we actually get those texts
to both of our phones we use this app
called community where it sends text to
us we respond to as many people as we
can we even respond to some folks here
on the podcast now during the lightning
round store ryan and i do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like and now you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com yeah carolee has a
question
how about a basic overview of how to
manage it all emails documents photos
it's overwhelming well we will dive deep
on the maximal this week on some
specific methods and how to's let's
understand
the why two first now i alluded to this
earlier but here's my pithy answer for
you doing less is not about the doing
it's about
the less
and i found that out viscerally with
this new computer and it was so
freeing because i didn't have to do and
i was dreading it in fact i remember
right after i brought the computer home
you asked me ryan i didn't set it up for
close to a week and you were asking
how's the new computer i'm like i don't
know and it's because i was afraid of
what
everything i had to do
with the computer and it turns out i
didn't have to do anything except turn
it on
and when you remove all of the excess
doing
then there's a type of being and it's so
much
less
overwhelming you got something pithy for
us for sure uh you know i got the first
one i have here is henry david thoreau
uh it's it is wait yeah it is not enough
to be busy
so are the ants
yes the question is what are we busy
about
and that that's the first thing that
came to mind because emails and
documents and photos and always have to
do do do do and i have all this
available to me so you know i must uh
manage it appropriately and use it as
much as possible but i don't want to use
it too much i mean
why are you doing it yeah that's that's
really the question my pithy answer here
the second one i have here is when in
doubt go without so
you know kind of going back to the
should i upgrade rule uh-huh just go
without it for a little bit see how it
goes yes yeah yeah and so when you're
looking at any of these things
carefully whether it's email documents
photos what is the reason that it's so
overwhelming
it's taxing you i get it and yes there
are ways to organize and file things
away i'm going to talk about some of
those but the the thing that i want to
understand is what is overwhelming me
and can i actually do
without it you know what man i uh
so you know i was having like an email
issue and i literally at a certain point
i was like i'm just gonna send an email
to everyone who's important and say i am
no longer using email
send me a text or call me if you need
anything
uh i did not but i mean it wasn't that
radical of an idea like at the time
because i was getting so frustrated with
it right but uh but yeah i mean if if
email's stressing you out see what it's
like to go without it for a little bit
you can always bring it back into your
life these things are incredibly
valuable to us right until they're not
and so if email is something that is a
tool for you that's not overwhelming you
great yeah if it begins to overwhelm you
well then that is a sign that is being
used in a way
that
exceeds the my expectations or my
expectations exceed my capabilities here
right and so
overwhelm is a sign
it's a sign of what that we need to let
go of something a new management system
alone is not going to help you out in
fact there's a great chance it's going
to make you more stressed
more suffering what did we say earlier
ryan use your suffering to ease your
suffering well what does that mean it
means that
if you're suffering so much you get
tired of the suffering you get tired of
the overwhelm and if you are fed up with
the overwhelm
it doesn't matter what system you use if
you're truly overwhelmed sometimes the
best thing to do is simply walk away
because as you said earlier with the
video games with email with anything
else you can always walk back to it yeah
if it and use it differently
once you've removed it from your life
for a period of time you can use it
reintroduce it in a way that adds value
to your life
we got a bunch more to talk about ryan
including some danny and and emma and
mallory i've got an awesome added value
this week but you got something for us
first ray yeah man here's some voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
check them out hi my name is catherine i
currently live in the bay area
and i was calling to comment on your
episode three which talks about children
and what i do with my children that
helps
every
um first week of december um with
clutter my children go through all of
their toys and we wash them we clean
them we put them in cute little bags and
then we donate them to
centers around our community and they
love acting like santa
and
sharing
their toys and stuff and
it gives us kind of that pre-christmas
plurage period
um
also
we
have we live in an rv full-time and so
having that limited a space has
definitely helped us with the
grandparents and that kind of stuff with
they give us more experiences than stuff
since they know we just physically don't
have room
hello josh hello ryan my name is sandra
and i currently live in zurich
switzerland
i want to recommend the books that might
hopefully bring a lot of inspiration to
you and your listeners
in my profession as a designer i have
found myself often challenged with a
consumption oriented mindset of the
industry and although i work in
publishing mostly designing books
i would still find myself often wishing
that i could bring more of a positive
change into this world with my work
but i never really knew how
then i found a book called the little
red book about how to make design matter
by david carlson and it inspired me so
much that i decided to share it with you
in my opinion any person designer or not
can find value in it because it
encourages the reader to make their work
more meaningful
and then guides you with simple
inspiring examples
i really can't express enough how much
this book has changed for me
has made a change for me and how excited
i now feel to make all the ideas happen
all right joe we got a bunch more
surprise questions this thursday on
patreon that's the maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast it's way
longer than this we do one hour
sometimes two hours sometimes three plus
hours only if tk's here
well quite often we do we do an hour and
a half two hours we really dive deep
into some stuff but first real quick
right here right now here's one thing or
maybe two things going on or three
things going on in the life of the
minimalist we're expanding our team last
week you met danny unknown like i said
we they each have to have a that's his
his social media handle so i didn't make
that up for him isn't it strange that we
have jordan no more and danny unknown
both on the team and of course we have
podcast sean which some
lovely listener came up with early on
into the podcast says we were always
referring to sean and someone sent him
an email and just called him podcast
sean and yeah it has stuck ever since
and now we have mallory and emma emma
the immigrant i'm not really sure what
to
call her we don't have a perfect
nickname for her yet let us know on
youtube and then mallory's from alabama
so i don't know if it's alabama or
or something oh that's good i like that
oh that's good i just wish they could
all be named sean
that would be easy so we worked with two
sean's right right yeah it was
fascinating we had our first team
meeting with him we don't call it team
meeting we were we actually called a joy
committee big shout out to millie who
had applied for one of uh these
positions she was awesome and we just
couldn't hire everyone that we loved
and um she talked about doing these joy
committees at her job she set it up i'm
like wow that's what i want because we
want i hate meetings but i love joy and
so
it's it's kind of like packing up my
stuff i hate packing up stuff but you
put party on it right it's awesome how
could it be a joy party ooh
ryan will definitely be there he shows
up with like a case under each arm
of sparkling water yes um anyway so we
have we're expanding the team and it was
fascinating we were doing this meeting
and i i made a list of everyone who's
like direct who's on the immediate team
and then we have an expanded team like
jeff and dave
and and other folks we work with
regularly uh alan and andrew and sarah
and and i realized like oh my gosh
the minimalist is like 31 people at this
point it's crazy and uh or at least 25
of people we work with regularly right
and then we have a couple of side
businesses as well like minimalism life
and our coffee shop down in in florida
if you counted all the people who work
at the coffee shop it would be really
crazy but yeah
what's fascinating is ryan and i have
had the opportunity to be the face of
this thing but it's really about the
people who help us share this message
because
ryan has said recently that we're not in
the advice business
we're in the healing business
and what i've really learned over the
last decade is a lot of people have a
unfortunate or tumultuous
or just
overwhelming relationship with stuff and
so for us minimalism starts with
healing that relationship with stuff so
we can really really heal our
relationship with ourselves so
danny and mallory and emma are here to
help us
heal
people and their relationship with stuff
welcome aboard joe yeah
all right well we've got an added value
segment today oh before we get to the
added value ryan um since we are talking
about digital clutter we've got this
thing over at minimalist.org which is
our free local meetup groups we have 100
different meetup groups eight different
countries
and
we also have an online city so if you
don't have if you live in the middle of
nowhere and portugal we may not have a a
group right next to you but we have this
online city with i don't know 14 000
people in it who all just interact with
each other it's all free minimalist.org
but this month because we had our new
book come out last month love people use
things we have this challenge on there
the love people use things challenge and
there are a few things on here i wanted
to highlight so the first 10 days of the
month this month we did a digital
declutter challenge i'll give you a few
examples of those how many photos do you
have on your phone if you wanted to
reflect back on your meaningful memories
would it be a beautiful experience or an
overwhelming task today we're
challenging you to go through your phone
and delete 100 photos or consider
deleting a thousand photos in the next
11 days there's a link to an article in
there as well there are a few other
challenges in here deleting 10 of the
apps on your phone today how will that
make you feel which ones truly add value
to your life we have another one screen
list saturdays that's always something
that's helpful three different ways to
embrace screenless saturdays so you can
find that over at
minimalist.org the online city over
there for added value this week ryan
sometimes
it feels like life gets crazy we get
overwhelmed
and we always look back to oh remember
when it was so much simpler how many
times do people come up to us at our
tour stops or on the road and they're
like
i remember when everything i own could
fit in my car and i was so much happier
than but then of course
life got crazy
so let's play with a song this is from
mike his new album which is called the
highs the song is called life got crazy
it's a perfect reminder that life gets
crazy when we over complicate things
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like
how do i determine which smartphone apps
to delete what are the best ways to
curate and store my physical photographs
how do i declutter the duplicate photos
on my smartphone what should i do with
my old dvds and cds
can i just toss my dead batteries in the
trash
ryan the answer to this is going to
surprise you it certainly shocked me the
answer from the forest service it's a
bit nuanced though so we'll talk about
what to do with dead batteries i'm a
little shocked i'm still a little
trepidatious right now plus we've got
nine things you can do with old
computers and other electronic devices
and of course a million more questions
for the minimalists
and if you want to hear all that join us
on the minimalist private podcast this
week visit patreon.com the minimalist to
subscribe and get your personal link so
that our private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you also get access
to
recordings of our live events to our
archives hundreds of hours of minimalism
our ask the minimalist anything sessions
and our patreon community you can follow
the minimalist on facebook twitter and
instagram at minimalists come to one of
our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com the
minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive our
simple sunday emails whenever we send
those out and if you leave here today
with just one message let it be this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it